terrifying moments for Benedict
Cumberbatch and his family when a
knife-wielding man attacked their UK
home it happened when police say Jack
Bissell kicked through the home's front
gate before spitting on the intercom
then using a fish knife to tear it apart
that move ultimately helped please track
him down thanks to DNA Left Behind now
it's unclear when this all happened but
Bissell pled guilty to the attack on May
10. he was given a three-year
restraining order forbidding him to be
anywhere near the doctor strange star or
his family
trespassing in this city and on this
planet according to reports a motive for
the attack has not been revealed and
Bissell who was working as a chef
doesn't seem to have a connection to
Cumberbatch he was charged with criminal
damage and fined 250 pounds which is
about 300 US Dollars now thankfully the
family never came face to face with
Bissell during the ordeal Benedict who
likes to keep his personal life private
married wife Sophie hunter in 2015 and
the couple Share three sons kid Hal and
Finn
Ichi caught up with the Emmy winner just
days after they tied the knot he was
beaming as a newlywed and soon-to-be new
dad you got family back here my wife any
shot that there'll be a photobomb today
if they want but I'm not I'm not doing
that I got a photo bump to look after
foreign